how are you doing first of all it's a
weird time we're all in quarantine like
how are you holding up
it's definitely an unfunded time for
most but we've just been making the most
of it
of course definitely keeping Ally out of
the public because it she does have a
compromised immune system and we that's
the last thing we would want I mean it's
terrifying for her to even have the flu
so this is it was very scary for us and
they actually have been separated from
their dad for a little while be because
he's still working in the public Wow
so I mean I think I saw used to poke out
about this too you posted something
about like urging people to please stay
at home for like as paint over your
daughter and you know at-risk people and
others that have compromised immune
systems are very vulnerable to this
disease you know we it's so unknown we
don't you know we're learning as it
unfolds as we're seeing you know we're
seeing the results as it happens so I I
definitely am urging everyone to stay at
home for the sake of my Ally and anyone
else that may have compromised immune
system or maybe it at risk to this virus
yeah absolutely so how does I mean a lot
of people are co-parenting in this
strange time how are you what are you
guys doing so they're not seeing their
dad right now no he's still working in
the public yeah oh we don't want her to
be exposed whatsoever
so we've just honestly we whenever it
first kind of started unfolding we
that's when we start staying calm way
before through stay at home orders in
place we were just kind of like go home
you know let's see what what is about to
transpire here and yeah it is they it
wasn't really because we took vacations
and they've had like a couple weeks away
from each of us like when we went on
vacation but for the most part we just
don't want her to be exposed to it just
like we wouldn't want anyone else
exposed to it so we've just been staying
and since then and really I mean we did
a couple drive-bys so we definitely
let them get out and see their dad but
sir they're missing they're missing
their family on that side right yeah so
what kind of things are you guys doing
cuz you're talking about making the best
of it like are we doing like craps like
what do we got going on girl yes yes
Queen we are we have been painting
anything that I could really get them
into rather be you know outside when the
weather is nice playing hopscotch
drawing little things on I don't know
trees and riding it you know I took them
on a little hike um painting we have
little easels that had kind of tucked
away and brought those out we've been
playing Candyland I've never played
Candyland emoji you know so much of my
life but so we're but we're making the
best of it where it's nice that we have
each other
you still film the show right like
you're still yes we're didn't filming
virtually right now wow what is that
like I love my producer I'm so he's
amazing all microc the crew that comes
they're amazing they love the kids we're
actually missing them a whole lot right
now I was curious because like just
being on the show for so long do you
think about not having the cameras and
what kind of keeps you doing it year
after year is what that producer is it
something else
um well Ali said the other day I really
want MTV to come back because they're
like family now just like I don't want
to ever stop filming it's like what you
know whatever stop filming and that's
Ali she doesn't I don't know they just
love it um it's like they're part of our
life now yeah so you don't think about
that coming to an end any time soon
I mean I know that it eventually will
yeah it was eventually yeah I mean but I
don't I don't really I'm really thinking
about I don't think too much in the past
or future
you know like staying in the moment and
whatever's meant to happen isn't it to
happen
yeah like that dating you know what I
mean okay so let's jump into this memoir
you wrote it is heartbreaking it is
shocking but I
to know what it felt like for you to put
pen to paper and why did you decide you
wanted to share these aspects of your
life with the world so I feel like
everyone looked at me and they see the
girl that was on 16 and pregnant the
girl that was an all-star cheerleader I
had everything hand out for her and just
got pregnant at a young age but little
do they know there's so much more to my
story that wasn't shown in the series of
teen months you the child abuse that I
endured as a child and that reflected on
the decisions I made and early my really
adult life I just really wanted my
supporters and viewers it was also very
therapeutic for me to write to kind of
just go back to those those days and
connect with those emotions and how many
feels like a very chilling process also
but it was also alright that's alright
I would I would I would be fronting if I
told you it wasn't hard
did it start out like just were you like
I'm gonna publish this or did it kind of
start out like I'm just gonna write down
everything I'm feeling on paper and then
it kind of turned into this book yeah
when I went away Arizona that's when I
kind of started writing and really
letting everything out on on paper that
I had gone through and connecting with
the trauma that I endured really working
through that and that that's what that's
why the purpose and I know that I don't
want anyone else to feel alone I don't
want anyone else to feel ashamed of
their story so I was like I get to speak
up I get to use my voice I get to speak
my truth you spent your entire adult
life on reality TV with the cameras like
we all get to make mistakes in our youth
and nobody has to see it and nobody ever
has to know about it you make mistakes
for the world to see so I mean I I don't
know how you do I don't know how you do
it sometimes I know you brought an
excerpt for us from hope grace and faith
to read this this is like this is I am
so proud because you know my girls have
that role model to look up to so
yes do you mean is it go ahead and read
it yeah let's do this it was my girls
that saved my life
they were my strength when I felt too
weak to fight they were the light when
all I could see was darkness they were
in the rainbow on the other side of the
storm that brought sunshine and joy back
to my life most people fall into
addiction because they're trying to mask
the symptoms of anxiety and depression
without confronting or sometimes even
acknowledging the root cause that was as
true for my dad as it was for me I'm
still working on myself growing as a
person and striving to be the best
mother that I can be it isn't always
easy
I am tested daily but if I stumble I
pick myself up again and keep moving
forward
I can't control what life throws at us
but what I can do is teach my daughters
to live with live their lives with hope
grace and faith thank you oh thank you
thank you okay
let's dive into this so you talked about
your up but how are you doing are you
okay I'm good okay good I mean how does
it feel reading that how does it feel
reading it back and you know it's about
to come out to the world there was
definitely a lot of fears that came up
but I'm pretty I'm ready um oh I'm okay
with who I am and I'm okay with being
the woman that I'm meant to be or in the
mother that I'm meant to be and
everything that I got all the adversity
that I have faced throughout the short
amount of time here on earth um I it's
made me who I am
and I don't regret it if it feels good I
mean it honestly feels good just that
you know to say that yeah so who in your
life were you worried you most nervous
or are you most nervous just share this
this way
I'm really not I didn't just owning it
mm-hmm
for the world to see yeah because I've
been I've been 100% honest with Jeremy
Corey my mom and everyone I mean is
still in my mom still learning mom I'm
still growing um she it was it was hard
for her to read yeah well I mean how did
she how did she react when she read it
and how was your guys relationship today
uh when she read it she cried yeah I
think she definitely had some fears come
up for her as well but our relationship
today and the complete change in our
entire family dynamic is or has made it
all worth it so me owning everything
that I've been through and really like
telling my story and being okay with
that has allowed them to do the same so
my mom can only do what she was taught
and I had to unlearn everything that I
was taught and now she gets to unlearn
everything that she was taught to to be
a better grandmother a better mom and I
couldn't be more proud of who she is
today you talk about your upbringing and
kind of how it it you know let into your
your adult life what did you learn from
like reflecting on this on your
upbringing and writing this that you
want to or that you've applied to like
your own parenting with your girls um to
truly love myself yeah you really love
myself for Who I am no matter what I've
been through
even if my parent you know even if I was
abandoned as a child even if I was
abused as a child
none of that defines my life now so I've
definitely I've definitely learned a far
as co-dependent relationships being okay
with just me and loving myself and being
alone like that's okay
and then being that if that role model
for my girls I always said if there's
one thing I wanted you know I I wanted
to give my kids the life I didn't have
and I'm doing that that's great um I
will say that you mentioned like you're
okay with being alone I love that that's
a great journey but you I feel like I
felt like you almost like beat yourself
up too much because you were talking
about how you were like I'm like sifting
through the wreckage of these like two
failed marriages I'm like how did I get
here and I was like you are doing fine
okay do you think about like at this
point now that you do know yourself so
well do you think about dating again
finding love like what do you feel like
the next step is are you just like I'm
good and if something happens it happens
that's exactly right I'm not gonna find
someone really soon I I mean as much as
I would love to share the joy and
happiness that I feel like I would love
to share that with someone but I'm
perfectly content with the way life is
it just feels so great I listen I love
Mike I'm gonna stay the whole time I
love my girl game I love being a girl
mom I wouldn't have it any other way
um I'm open to dating I'm open to dating
but I'm not my focus is 100 playin all
the way on my oh my kids I would love to
share that I would love to have a
healthy relationship for them to look up
to eventually but it will come but I
feel like this this attitude now where
you're like I'm not codependent that's
when you find like the partner and not
the person that you rely on you find
like a partner all right yes yes I will
find the partner you also reflected a
lot about being on reality TV and like I
said like you've had cameras falling
you're your entire adult life so if you
could go back I mean going into reality
TV people are like a naive about what
it's really like and how they kind of
edit down the footage to create a
narrative if you could go back would you
do it all over again did make me feel
bad I mean I
yes I would do it all over again because
I have the platform that I do to make a
difference in the world and if anyone
knows me and every single interview I've
probably ever done I've just I've wanted
to make a difference and that's that's
still my passion but still my passion if
I could if I could save one life from
addiction one life from suicide like
that's that's where my heart is and I I
don't regret that not at all what's
something you think about back then that
you're like I wish I knew that now like
if somebody was like 16 17 years old
going into reality TV what's something
you would warn them about or tell them
about I'm not sure anyone that 16 of
second ish ago it's a reality TV yeah
probably not not no unless you've grown
up around that world I didn't know I
mean when I first started receiving
feedback from the you know the fans I
was true where I was so crushed because
I'm very I'm I'm such a loving person I
am I I am and it was it was hard for me
like it took it definitely took a toll
on me so if I I would say to anyone
that's going into reality television at
such a young age to know your worth know
what you're like know what you're
capable of love yourself and it doesn't
matter no judgment like I never take you
just knowing you're worth knowing that
it doesn't matter what anyone says about
you at then at the end of the day you
like you know what how you feel about
yourself you know yeah yeah I don't
think anyone like at 16 or 17 can take a
negative comment and just like let it
roll off like somebody no sure could no
yeah yeah I I was I mean I was I went to
a movie theater and was jumped on a
movie theater it's in my book because I
was on a reality television show
and I was I'm such a kind person that I
was like what is that wrong at 17 18
years old
I can't imagine seeing someone on a
reality television show and even like
saying anything to the sulfa let alone
I want to get into some of the the more
concerning stuff he wrote I mean you
opened up about this night where you
contemplated suicide almost driving off
a cliff
I mean that was like hard to even read
let alone write I mean why did you why
did you decide to share that story
particularly if I can save one person
from taking their life and allow them to
see that their life is truly worth
living
then my story in my book was worth it in
writing that story was worth it and if I
was gonna own my story and my truth then
I was gonna let it all out there you
know I was gonna I was there wasn't
there literally there's nothing in my
book or in my life that had happened
that I left out of my book because it
would you know I wanted to be vulnerable
I wanted to own that and and so it like
you look look at the statistics now
there's so many that are suffering from
that or they feel alone and not that's
my only hope is that others don't feel
alone they don't feel like their life is
worth taking because all of our lives is
worth living and that that's that's why
I really got that deep in my book yeah
what I mean I think about now wherever
one is like some people are isolated by
themselves like mental health is a
really can real big concern so do you
have like a mantra or message that you
kind of tell yourself in this timer is
there you know how are you making sure
that you are coping mentally during this
time as well or support I reach out for
support if you need someone to talk to
don't ever be afraid to reach out don't
ever be a scared or ashamed of your
story that's that's why I say own your
story I'll own your journey you know
it's okay we all have these feelings or
emotions that come up it's when we
bottled them in that they affect us
negatively you know mm-hmm yeah you also
open up about opioid addiction which is
like this very common pattern of people
getting hooked on prescription
medication and not really
realizing that things have gone too far
so can you talk about that moment when
you realized that things had gotten out
of hand when you realize you actually
needed help when I was when I wanted to
take my own life when I wanted to commit
suicide that's when I realized I there
was an underlying issue that I wasn't
wanting to open up about or even talk
about um and that's what really I mean
that that being suicidal I'm wanting to
take my life and leave my girls without
a mom is what led me to see you know I'm
nine needed help and that was it and it
was okay you talked about MTV like
producers being like mentioning that you
who I couldn't keep your eyes open like
how like did they help you get help did
they get involved it's like who stepped
into you do yeah most um my management
and MTV ceptin and let me know I
honestly I look back at that footage and
I draw blanks a draw blanks to that
period of my life because it doesn't
seem like that was like it doesn't it
doesn't even I look at it I'm like was
that really me was that really nodding
off like was I really under that much
medication it just didn't even dawn on
me until I was finally like I don't even
want to live anymore I'm not worth it
like my life's not worth living and I
still didn't see it I thought I could do
it all on my own I thought I could do it
all on my own and there's a I feel like
there's a stigma against any treatment
facility that it's only on addiction
which mind you there's nothing wrong
there's nothing wrong with fighting
addiction or having an addiction and
overcoming that it's just reaping off
for support but there's a stigma on
treatment facilities and there's
multiple tracks that you can be a part
of whether that's trauma addiction
whatever it may be like there was some
people that I was in the treatment
facility with that just needed two weeks
to themselves like they were having a
really hard time and that's okay there's
nothing wrong with reaching out for the
support
thank God I had people that held me high
mm-hmm in that time in my life because I
wasn't holding myself high yeah I didn't
see my own self-worth you also open up
about this this miscarriage abortion
story which has gained a lot of traction
on the Internet's everything happened so
quickly it seemed like you had to make
this decision like essentially overnight
so literally okay yeah like how do you
feel about that decision now that you've
had time to reflect now that you've
written about it like how do you feel
clearly yeah would it mean I mean I
don't know I don't I don't regret any
decision that I made because it has made
me the person that I am today had I been
Who I am today maybe I wouldn't make
that decision but I also don't I don't
get to I'm not gonna I don't choose to
dwell and that and that period of my
life where I I didn't own my story where
I didn't know my truth where I felt
unworthy of love where I um I mean it
was hard and honestly the only thing
that I regret from that period of my
life is just not owning it then not
being honest that yeah because like I
think you have a lot of fans that may
have felt like they were lied to enjoy
yeah yeah I definitely feel like I have
a lot of fans that felt disappointed or
you know felt like they they were lied
to
and that's that's the last that that's
blessing I would want any anyone to bill
that supports me and my journey and I
just I definitely would have been more
considerate yeah yeah
okay you wrote that Cory you don't even
know if Cory knew the truth back that or
to this day you don't know if he still
know the truth this you know now I'm I
mean I'm sure he does now yeah um but I
also don't
I mean he's happy with his family and we
all get along great
so I don't I hope and nothing would have
changed if we were meant to be we would
stop we would be together if Germany and
I've come into being we would be
together so there's nothing that I you
know would do any different
[Music]